it says find the equation of the tangent
line to the graph of f of x equals x
squared minus 1 at the point 2 3 so we
know y equals x squared that's just a
parabola -1 shifts the graph down 1 but
what we're gonna try to do here is we're
going to find the equation of this
tangent line right here okay so it just
barely touches the parabola at the point
2 3 now when you find the equation of a
line what do you need you need a point
right and you need a slope okay so what
we're gonna do is we're going to use the
difference quotient to find the
derivative and then remember the
derivative really represents the slope
anywhere along this graph keep in mind
that over here the slope is negative
here at zero here it's positive here
it's even more positive so we want to
find a formula that will allow us to
find the slope at this point so let's
get into the difference quotient right
here applied to this equation okay so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say alright let me just pick a different
marker here let's do the black so we'll
do X plus h squared minus 1 so all I did
was I put X plus h into our function in
place of X minus f of X which is the
original function okay so minus x
squared minus 1 I put it in parenthesis
want to treat it as a group all divided
by H and we're looking at the limit as H
approaches zero okay so you probably saw
this in the previous video how these
points become closer and closer together
until they coincide at that same point
you're finding that instantaneous rate
of change you can check out that video
if you want to learn more about that but
here we're going to simplify so we've
got x squared plus 2 HX plus h squared
okay I filed that out minus 1 minus x
squared plus 1 because I'm distributing
the negative ok all divided by H and
notice the X Squared's are cancelling
one another out the ones are cancelling
one another out and we're left with two
HX plus h squared divided by H you can
factor an H out of the numerator so that
you can cancel those HS out okay
remember this is a limit as H approaches
zero so if we put zero in for H okay
this is going to zero we're just left
with 2x so 2x is our formula for our
derivative okay F prime of X equals 2x
okay that's the formula for the
derivative so if we want to find the
slope at this point 2 3 when X is 2 ok
if we put 2 in here we get 2 times 2 so
f prime of 2 equals 4 ok so that means
the slope of this blue line the tangent
line is going to be 4 so I'll just write
that in here so M equals 4 and we have
the point 2 3 so you can use the slope
intercept form but if you have a point
in a slope it's gonna be easier to use
the point-slope form so just a quick
refresher here point-slope form is y
minus y1 equals M times X minus x1 M is
the slope of the line and x1 y1 is the
point that the line goes through so we
have y -3 okay equals 4 times X minus 2
now I'm just going to rewrite them to
solve for y so I'll just distribute the
4 that's 4x minus 8 and then we're gonna
add the 3 and the other side okay to get
the Y by itself so that's 4x minus 5